محاولات انتحار وحالات اكتئاب وسبع حالات
فقدان ذاكره هذه تفاصيل كشفت عنها وزاره
الصحه بالسودان قائله ان هذا من تبعات
الحرب التي دارت بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
اداره الصحه النفسيه في وزاره الصحه
السودانيه قالت للعربيه ان الاكتئاب يقف
على راس قائمه الاضطرابات النفسيه لدى
كبار السن اما ابرز الاضطرابات النفسيه
لدى الاطفال فتمثلت في البكاء الشديد
والتبول اللاارادي والخوف والهلع كما كشفت
اداره الصحه عن محاولات انتحار في كسلا
شرق السودان وسط توقعات بزياده معدلات
الاصابه بالاضطرابات النفسيه الصحه
النفسيه كشفت انها اتاحت قنوات اتصال
مختلفه لمعرفه الاوضاع الراهنه وتقديم
خدمات الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي